Let's go next to our caller from the 8 1 area
code who's calling today from 2 8 1.
Exodus.
Sam, can you hear me?
Yes, and what's going on?
Well, you see, I'm in a pickle.
I got a call from my brother and he said that
it hits the fan that he's going to describe
over and then take me to our family bunker
square, they have apparently to three years
worth of food stored up.
And basically my whole family is convinced
the world's about that.
OK.
And I want to know, do you have a doomsday
plan?
And is it even worth it to form a doomsday
OK.
Good.
So just so I understand, Sam, is your family
of a particular religious faith?
Oh, yeah, sure, buddy.
It's fine.
But those are the ones who are the ones who
are most into prepping are not extra religious.
But I do come from a Catholic family.
Oh, okay.
All right.
That's interesting.
And then we're in the country.
Is this all happening?
So my family lives in South Dakota.
These are the bunkers apparently in Montana
and I live in Texas.
And did you not?
You knew about the existence of this bunker
writers?
What was the news of?
It also knew oh, it was news once we got that
phone call.
Oh, you didn't even know your family had this
bunker.
I know.
I do not know.
So I've learned a lot of things in a few days
and they're apparently like getting it ready.
Wow.
So listen here.
Here's my view.
I do believe it makes sense to have to do
basic preparedness.
And we've interviewed a couple of preparedness
experts and their view tends to be it doesn't
really make sense to plan for the events that
sort of have never happened and aren't like
in the reasonable scope of what what you can
kind of plan for.
It makes sense to plan for more likely things
so you can't leave your house at all for three
days or the food supplies interrupted for
a couple of weeks or something like that.
So from everything I've read, the most reasonable
thing to do is to have some some amount of
first aid supplies, certainly nonperishable
food that would last a couple of weeks in
a stock that you're not regularly using, you
know, to feed yourself.
And, you know, certainly now people are thinking
it makes sense to have some masks, some N-95
masks.
When this is all done, I'm sure there will
be a lot of people that are going to debate
basic preparedness.
But, you know, saying everyone should have
a Montana bunker with three years of food.
I mean, first of all, it's laughably unaffordable
for the vast majority of the country, number
one.
Now, that's not a reason not to do it, but
it seems from the survival experts I've spoken
to that that's probably more than what really
is logical.
Are you.
Are you telling me that amassing like 40 guns
and the like, 30 gallons of rice and sticking
it in a hole in the middle of nowhere is not
it's not like a logical thing.
That may not be the most logical thing I've
ever heard of.
Right.
But but but, you know, once it hits the fan,
once things actually do crumble, you're gonna
be like, gosh, I wish I had that bunker.
I don't know.
I mean, no, listen, it's completely true.
Like, so about a year and a half ago, I did
some disaster preparedness.
And I. I have kids that are in both of both
of the cars that my girlfriend that I have.
And then we've got some supplies at home.
And then we've built up kind of our non-perishables
in a very, very reasonable way.
And I think that a lot more people are going
to be doing that.
And now, I mean, listen, I'm keeping a list
of things that once things settle down, if
I survive all of this, I want to to have just
to feel, OK, so like, for example, now that
we know about the run on masks, okay, maybe
I'll get 20 masks or, you know, 50 masks or
some number and have them for whenever, just
so I don't have to worry about it.
Right.
I put it out of my head, so to speak, or whatever.
I think that we're going to see more people
certainly do that once this all settles down.
Yeah, and then but certainly the smart thing.
And so I definitely wish you luck if society
does crumble, I hope that you're able to find
a Montana bunker.
Thank you.
All right.
Very good.
Email me the address or the coordinates or
whatever, and we will we will keep that on
file.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate the phone call.
Let me take a quick break.
Don't hang up because we will be right back
with your phone calls after this.